THRONE.
IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S HASHTAG
WAR.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
LET'S KEEP IT GOING.
THANKS, GUYS.
THANKS FOR JOINING IN.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU GUYS A
HASHTAG.
BUZZ IN WITH AS MANY TWEET AS
YOU CAN.
FOR EACH CORRECT EXAMPLE YOU GET
250 POINTS.
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS BAD
SERIALS.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE GROPE NUT.
OUR LUMPY CHARM.
OR DISHONOR ABLE DISCHARGED
CAPTAIN CRUNCH WITH
DINGLEBERRIES.
DEON.
>> CO-CO-PUFF-PUFF-PASS.
>> TOM?
>> CAPTAIN FELCT.
>> KYL?
>> OAT BLISTERS.
>> DEON.
>> FROSTER FLAKES.
>> KYLE?
>> HONEY BUNCHES OF RADISHES.
>> YOU BET.
POINT.
TOM?
>> APPLE JACK-OFFS.
( APPLAUSE )
>> POINT.
THAT'S PART OF A BALANCED BRK
FAST.
KYLE.
>> ROCKY DENNIS' CLUMPY MASH
MALLOW FACES.
THE MASK JOKE.
>> YEAH, I KNOW, I CAN'T-- OH,
CRAP.
I'LL GIVE YOU POINT.
TOM DEON.
>> EARLY MORNING KELLOGG.
>> AH, NO, THEY DIDN'T BACK YOU
UP ON THAT ONE.
ONE MORE, KYLE.